so Seth Meyers is leaving SNL to host
his own late-night talk show can he make
the Shelby's own only if he becomes a
master of social media ever since Johnny
Carson retired the late-night talk show
format is felt exactly the same as when
Johnny Carson retired open with topical
jokes then commercials then guests
flocking for some new product than
commercials skits commercials
commercials commercials in a desperate
attempt to appear relevant show hosts
are now leveraging social media for all
they're worth Conan O'Brien is a Twitter
maestro and he's got the funniest
profile on linkedin Jimmy Fallon does
mashups and viral videos and
incorporates hashtags into his humor
hashtag dinosaurs hashtag how do they go
extinct hashtag meteor and millions who
don't watch Jimmy Kimmel saw his viral
torque fail hoax video there's only one
way Meyers could beat his competitors at
their own game he's got to cut out the
middleman and create his own social
networking platform it's simple Seth
round out the best writers he can find
no not not comedy writers code writers
come up with a brand name some common
word that's missing a foul for some
reason they're always missing a bow here
how about this
Oh brainstorm add geolocation features
so that you can narrow cast jokes and
advertising messages to each community
member it worked like so hi there thanks
for watching hope you're doing well out
in Duluth Minnesota how about the
weather there huh it's currently what's
up with that and what's up with your
local sports team the way they've been
playing lately you'd think that they
stack overflow error at line 327 huh
okay it's still got some kinks that need
working out but it's still better than
the desk and couch paradigm what is your
least favorite talk show skit let me
know in the comments